all right so compliance is directed
hello this is this Chris Duckman the
Chris document of YouTube yes yes I
would love it if you would take your
shirt off for me you want me to take off
my shirt yes please I really want to see
your underbelly I'm not gonna take off
my shirt for you sir I'm a police
officer and there are consequences for
this type of insubordination okay
compliance is based off of a true story
that happened and you know whenever I
see that in movies it's based on a true
story inspired by true events like yeah
okay whatever cuz it's always like some
crazy supernatural movie based off true
events you know it's like okay whatever
it takes place in a very busy fast food
restaurant it's right around lunchtime
it's the rush hour for all these workers
and they get a call from a police
officer and this guy tells them look one
of these people has stolen money from
you one of these workers you have to put
her in the back room and as the movie
progresses his requests over the phone
while claiming to be a police officer
get increasingly more personal and we
squirm in our seats until we can't take
it anymore he's saying you'll have to
take you to jail what we could do is
have you strip surger right now it's
been searching here no I did a lot of
research on this case after I saw the
movie and the details portrayed in this
film are painstakingly and unfortunately
very realistic this is one of the best
films I have seen all year I'm telling
you guys right now this is one of the
best movies to come out so far in 2012
it is incredibly disturbing to the point
where you are actually ashamed to call
yourself a human being living on this
planet because as this man claiming to
be a police officer is able to
manipulate these various people into
doing things that any human pretty much
would no this is not right
they're so affected by this presence of
supposed thority on the phone and the
consequences that could come with them
disobeying this authority they continue
to go forth with these actions that we
as the viewers are like screaming at the
screen like no no you know that's wrong
usually you're smarter than that and
that was a huge problem I have of this
until I realized that it actually is
true that almost every detail in this
film is how it happened with minor
dramatizations included there is parts
in this movie when I literally just
wanted to scream at the screen and I was
like what are you doing man you know no
you shouldn't do that you know you can't
do that because this person on the phone
was so convincing to be able to
continuously request these things to do
to this poor girl and it's the idea of
how humans cave in under the presence of
authority how far would you let yourself
get into a situation that you know is
wrong if you think there are some sort
of legal consequences this is okay I'm
just trying to do my job I do anything
yeah and you know what I gotta say this
is one of the best scripts of the entire
year because what this movie does is it
has a brilliant way of portraying the
way people actually talk not every
single line people say is some movie
dialogue that you're supposed to think
like wow that's a really great line a
lot of times people just sit there and
they talk about the weather or they talk
about what they had for breakfast or
they talk about you know their plan and
scheduling for the day just random
conversation small talk that people do
all the time that's rarely ever in
movies because people are always gonna
say you know that kind of dialogue isn't
interesting no one wants to hear that
this movie is unique in the way that it
shows what people actually talk about
when they're standing in front of the
cash register and there's no customers
right now and they're just sort of
itching the counter and looking for
something to clean what what do these
people actually talk about in this
situation from a filmmaking standpoint
directorial standpoint this movie is
very well done the film looks
magnificent there's long sequences of
sustained slow motion that for some
reason add to this strange odd dreamlike
quality of this movie that's really
important because when you're in a
situation that you never thought you'd
be in that's way over your head and you
think wow I could actually go to jail or
have some kind of legal ramifications it
does kind of feel like a dream because
you never think that's gonna happen to
you you always think you're just gonna
kind of coast through life and when you
actually do encounter a situation like
that it's very disturbing and
frightening and you feel like you're
kind of walking in slow motion and this
film portrays that very brilliantly
the hell is he doing back there I did a
bad thing that man's I sleep do things
today right
the performances are top-notch mainly
and out as the manager of this place who
is primarily the one on the phone for
the most of the time she was magnificent
so realistic she looks like the kind of
person that in real life you would just
yeah okay I totally buy her I've seen
her I know this person I've talked with
the report also dreama walker she's the
lead girl who is accused of the crime
initially by this police officer on the
phone and she was terrific in the movie
as well all the performances in this
movie right down to the two young
cashiers at this place are great none of
them feel like hey I'm in a movie right
now I'm gonna wink at the camera because
I know I'm being filmed that people are
watching me they all feel so realistic
like you're in this restaurant these are
all restaurant workers because when I
was a teenager I worked at fast food
places - I mean I think almost every
teenager has it at one point in time
worked at a restaurant I understand how
a lot of this works so realistically
portrayed but really the scariest thing
about this movie is the fact that it's
true and this all happened and if you do
research on it from news stories from
the past you will learn that and it's
very terrifying compliance is a movie
that is audience inclusive it encourages
an audience to get involved with it and
it actually makes you want to shout at
the screen and when a movie is able to
do that that's an impressive feat
they're almost like a real cop there
have been shouting matches at the q and
A's for this movie at various festivals
that premiered at people have walked out
of the film and you wonder why exactly
did they walk out they walk out because
the movie sucked or because they were so
affected by how realistic and disturbing
this movie is and actually afraid that
this happen in real life
compliance is one of the best films I've
seen all year I'm gonna give it an A if
it comes near you it's in limited
release right now definitely try to
check it out but be warned this is not
an entertaining movie in that normal
aspect it's a very disturbing film and
it will probably make you upset at
humanity for a while
I'll do everything you know that you
need thanks for watching guys and as
always if you like this then you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes